ces élus du département viennent de
voter une large majorité la fermeture du
collège bienvenue martin il met fin à un
feuilleton qui dure depuis des années
une décision difficile mais prise dans
l'intérêt des élèves
selon le président de l'assemblée le
fait de fermer bienvenue martin dans une
ville je les dis je le répète de 35000
habitants où il ya encore quatre
collèges situés tout autour avec des
transports urbains au sein de cette
agglomération et avec une mixité
justement qui va être une assertion qui
va être favorisés je ne trouve pas que
ce soit vraiment un grand malheur un
grand drame comme certains ont pu le
dire seul collège classé en zone
d'éducation prioritaire à auxerre situé
au coeur d'un quartier populaire
bienvenue martin est menacé de fermeture
depuis 2016 pour des raisons économiques
et démographiques
l'établissement qui accueille près de
400 élèves est vétuste et nécessitent
d'importants travaux
mes parents professeurs et élus vont se
mobiliser pour sauver le collège mais en
décembre 2018 la fenêtre d'une salle de
classe tombe
par mesure de sécurité les cours sont
suspendus
le collège provisoirement fermé et les
élèves affectés dans d'autres
établissements
après avoir refusé d'engager les travaux
nécessaires
le département a donc décidé de fermer
bienvenue martèle une fois pour toutes
une tragédie pour certains et du mois je
regrette amèrement cette décision
d'autant plus qu' elle n'a pas été
suffisamment travaillé nous ne savons
pas ce que va devenir ce lieu c'est
quand même c'était le dernier symbole de
la république dans ce quartier des eaux
d'auxerre et moi je suis navré du du
message que l'on envoie en enfermant ce
collège
c'est désormais au préfet de prendre
l'arrêté de fermeture définitive de
bienvenue martin il pourrait le faire
avant la fin de l'année